I'm sure this was a very personal
project I think I know for myself and
I'm sure I'd like to hear from you guys
your first exposure to the Prophet if
somebody gave it to me as a gift which I
think it is one of those books that
people give to other people like it's
not it tends to be something that people
share well it was given to me in college
and I hadn't I hadn't read it before and
the first time I opened it up I had just
met a friend we were just lying on the
floor and we just started reading the
book out loud I'm very interested in the
poetry of it was nice to hear out loud
and and really as the book went on and
on before even getting at the end I just
like had a very profound reaction to it
a very profound sort of shift of
consciousness where I had this intense
feeling of being connected to everything
and it sounds very trite to talk about
but it was very profound for me and I've
carried that with me
ever since it was you know one of those
books that I just always kept because I
think it's the kind of book that you
could just pull off the shelf and read a
few pages and get something from it so
then it wasn't until one day that
someone actually came along and said hey
would you be interested in doing some
kind of a movie based on this so then
that was kind of when I rediscovered it
recently well the same same story really
college it was required reading at my
drama school and like a lot of poetical
works we were encouraged to read them
out loud and I enjoyed the I enjoyed the
book but I remember being in anyway
profoundly hit by at the time but then
when this project came along and I read
you know I read the script and I and
when I went back to the book then you
know as someone hold a bit more
experienced probably more able to read
and understand the the complexity of the
work um you know it was beautiful it
struck me is very beautiful I saw the
cover of the book run next to my
grandfather's it was on his bedside
table always and the the drawing in the
cover of the book is by Callie
Geron because he's also an amazing
artist actually a lot of the animation
uses his arm his art especially on work
and keeps transforming it but um the
this picture of this man kind of haunted
me and it made me think of my
grandfather who was Lebanese and then he
died when I was six and I was very very
close to him and I was always wishing
that I had got to know him better and
that I could have him to ask him
questions about things that were going
in the family what would he think and
later on when I was about 18 I found
that man again that the cover and I read
for the first time the Prophet and so I
said can I borrow it and so when I read
it to me it was as if my grandfather was
teaching me about life through this book
but you know it's very true what you say
it's the kind of book that people give
and that's how you find it there was
never like a big mark marketing campaign
for this and actually this is the way it
has to happen with the movie because we
have no money for marketing and I just
hope that it's the kind of thing that if
you touch you you know people will talk
about it and you know tell the people to
go see it or give it to them the DVD is
a Christmas because I think this is the
on this is the destiny of this piece
that it's how it's gonna continue to
leave I really think that that will
happen I think that this is the 21st you
know century version there had been
trying to do this in live-action
and then when Claire came along he had
this great idea to do it into animation
but it was half the budget and it was
all poems and I thought the idea to make
it into animation was brilliant because
of many reasons but the freedom that
comes from I think the best way to tell
poetry is through music and images and
but
for me because it was so personal I I
thought it was gonna get lost I didn't
think it would be a good idea only
because it's so rich the poetry that if
you had thirteen poems that wouldn't
have been also this quality all of them
because it was half the budget and
thirteen of them it's just too much you
cannot really take you know the few
things you don't have to even understand
all the points sometimes it's just one
phrase that you needed to hear that's
what you need to do only what you don't
understand and you don't hear is because
it's not what you needed to hear the
most so I was afraid that it was just
gonna be too heavy but I was so excited
to be able to give life to the poetry
through animation and I believed that
the message of the film and of the
poetry was very important to tell today
it's not one messages many messages for
me also personally one was that there
was a an Arab writer that wrote a book
that has been he has sold more than 120
million copies around the world and that
has United every religion and Creed and
for many different generations and I was
excited to also bring light to this I
think in a day like today it was
important like do they know like five
years ago and but then the framing story
had to be very it was almost the biggest
challenge because for all the the
artists you know they would get the poem
and we promised absolute freedom for
them of course because they're artists
they wanted to collaborate with an
artist like Roger and bounce ideas and
created you know in harmony but at the
end
it was it was their gift for them to do
what they wanted and it was important
that it was artists that had different
religions different different age groups
from all over the world and the money
also came from all over the world we
wanted to have the spirit of Khalil
Gibran
in making of the film as well as what we
were trying to say with the film but the
framing story had to be simple enough
that the poems could take off and go
into an extraordinary visual journey and
Roger was very humble about this from
the beginning but it had to be smart
enough you know it had to have important
themes like freedom of speech a little
girl finding her own voice so that was
rich it was very very challenging for
him to write you know this story in a
way that it would be inclusive to
everyone and that it would it would be
the frame of these paintings the first
conversation we had was was about what
our goal was and that was to make a film
that could appeal that could be
accessible for all ages honestly when I
first agreed to do this I was thinking
oh well this is gonna be some art film
for adults right because it's all
philosophy and and then oh no we're
gonna make it for everybody so that was
an interesting challenge you know to
find a story that allowed a broad age
range the the idea of having the little
girl Salma came up with the suggestion
of having a little girl character and
that one was was a brilliant idea
because she would be a lot of the
children's guide to take them into the
story and lead them up to where all
these poems would be and the challenge
was to to write a story that could be
light and entertaining at times but not
go off too far so that we could come
back and make an easy transition into
some rather deep thoughts some deep
material so that was the balancing act
there
you've done a lot of other work but this
is especially this you're kind of
playing the heavy in it so talk about
that process oh very much so the heavy
the profile they gave me was lift you in
no doubt as to the characters weight
I've been bigger by the way no I think
that the beauty about animation is that
you're you're not reduced you you you
have to kind of you have to you have to
find something very very pure which is
just the voice just fine everything that
you can play with your body with your
with a glance with with a sort of
physical timing or an attitude that's
all denied you that's in the hands of
the animator and what the actor has is
to in a sense focus the vocal quality
into something absolutely specific and
of course when you're sometimes you work
before the animation is completed or
sometimes it's afterwards sometimes you
have to match the voice to an existing
image so it's always a very very
different experience but what was so
wonderful about this one was that we had
a you know we had a great deal of
freedom and we were recording and we
sort of we played around with different
accents different tone we thought I wish
it should he maybe he should be like is
he gonna be like a some kind of gruff
British working-class sergeant major
should we make him a bit more exotic we
were kind of playing around with stuff
and and week we I think we came up with
a character the work that I hope was
both tough and and kind of malevolent
but at the same time you know I wanted
to find the humor because because when I
first read the script I have to say it
made me laugh a great deal I thought was
very funny and I thought the you know
the the the the attitude of the sergeant
was wonderfully kind of pompous and you
know and so there was a lot of room for
that and and it was just I mean I don't
know yeah what you were saying about
animation being thought of as just for
kids I completely agree with you it's
it's a very frustrating assumption that
people make because there's a lot of
work goes into this a lot of thought a
lot of very careful analyzing and
distilling of all these different ideas
and and and contributions or all kinds
of creative people make and there's and
it can it comes down to something very
very pure which is really telling the
story in the simplest most direct way
and when I saw the film I realized that
all the sort of you know joshing around
we were having in the studio all the
kind of playing around with voices and
how about this what if I do that what if
I do a fart noise yeah how about that
you know all of that is really part of a
much bigger creative process you know
and it's you know I was saying to Roger
just now as we were waiting to come on
you know when you look at the number of
people that were involved in movies like
this it it you have to pause it's a
wonder movies get made at all you know
when you think of the amount of
dedication and time and effort and
commitment people would into it